this video is brought to you by vessy
footwear
[Music]
what's up wisecrack michael here to talk
about the most contentious
issue of 2020. one so divisive it could
destroy the fabric of society or at the
very least wreak havoc on your local
costco
you're coming closer that's right we're
talking about
masks or that humble six by nine inch
piece of fabric that manages to bring
thousands of grown-ups to tears
they want to throw god's wonderful
breathing system out the door
this potentially life-saving piece of
cloth that obscures approximately 56.2
percent of your face
is causing drama all over the country
especially amongst my fellow florida men
and by and large viral videos of these
maskless masses have yielded widespread
derision from the twitterati
but what if this is the wrong strategy
as people fundamentally obsessed with
both
not catching the plague and slam dunking
on pseudoscience
we at wisecrack are left wondering are
shame and ridicule the answer
how can we encourage our fellow wawa
patrons to hide their beautifully shaped
mouths
saying you left wawa i did because
voluntarily
because i refused to wear a mask believe
it or not this
is not a new problem public health
interventions have been inconveniencing
and annoying americans for years
whether we're being told to smash safely
stop exhaling secondhand smoke
or wear a seatbelt so some volunteer
firefighter doesn't have to scrape you
off the side of the road
but what if public health officials
learned from decades of trying to make
americans behave
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
america hates masks now what
but before we continue i'm gonna give a
shout out to bessie footwear for
sponsoring this video
a little while ago they sent over these
gray cityscape sneakers and as a
sneakerhead i was excited to test them
out
you see vessi's shoes are 100 waterproof
and while i'm not experiencing that much
rain in southern california
i thought these could be perfect for
when i do end up going home or on long
trips
vessies are the perfect everyday sneaker
they are lightweight stretchy and made
of dimetex material which is a dual
climate knit material that regulates
temperature no matter where
you are the best part is when you
purchase a pair of vessy shoes
you know your money is going towards
something great since the start of this
global pandemic
vessi has donated over 300 000 masks to
frontline workers
and they continue to give back to the
community just check out their page to
see how they're being active right now
you can get your own pair of vessies by
visiting vessy footwear dot com slash
wisecrack
when you use our link you'll get a
discount so check it out now
back to the show masks have been worn to
stem the spread of diseases to varying
degrees of success
since the 17th century when the
resurgence of the bubonic plague had
doctors looking like the stuff of
nightmares
fortunately modern doctors prefer the
more scientifically grounded and less
terrifying surgical or n95 masks
now for a quick primer on how masks work
in regard to covet
every time you open your gross pie hole
you spew invisible
disgusting droplets of your inner filth
when your aforementioned filth includes
tiny covet 19 particles
these droplets can make your fellow
humans sick masks worn correctly
block these droplets preventing others
from inhaling your disgusting lung juice
and that's probably why most americans
are wearing masks at least once per week
which okay is better than nothing
among the complicated and contentious
issues our country faces
this one seems like it should be about
as controversial as
please wear pants and denny's so why the
furious response to being told to cover
your face hole
to understand america's mask phobia
let's look back at the last time we were
asked to wear masks
not on halloween the 1918-1919 influenza
outbreak aka
the spanish flu it was a devastating
pandemic
ultimately afflicting around 500 million
people then
one third of the world's population it
was super
fatal particularly for healthy 20 to
40-somethings
afflicted countries relied on many of
the same public health strategies we
grumbly follow today
like neurotic hand washing and
cancelling every fun house party
except you know they didn't have netflix
or zoom trivia to help their sanity
and then there were the gauze masks
while they had become a common sight in
american hospitals
mask wearing by the masses was among the
most novel public health practices
introduced during this pandemic
according to historian nancy toms
as the flu spread public health
authorities across the country
encouraged people to make and wear these
masks
and some cities even passed laws
requiring them san francisco
issued such a mandate in october 1918
with detractors being subject to a fine
or up to 10 days imprisonment many other
cities and states attempted to do the
same but were stymied by resistance from
city council officials or boards of
health
as explained by university of michigan
researcher jay alexander navarro
and in places where laws were passed
they sometimes caused quite a stir
interestingly navarro notes that it was
mask ordinances rather than the very
strict lockdowns that seem to have
provoked the most anger from the masses
in response local governments were met
with intense defiance
sound familiar
one especially interesting parallel
between the two pandemics though
lies in who was wearing masks and who
wasn't according to a u.s national
library of medicine report
men were the weak links in hygienic
discipline in 1918.
a newspaper article from the time paints
a picture the average man wore the mask
slung to the back of his neck until he
came inside of a policeman
and most people had holes cut into them
to stick their cigars and cigarettes
through
recent polls have shown similar
mask-wearing reluctance amongst men
today
making the spanish flu era response to
maskless dude bros particularly
instructive for us
so how did we deal with these
mustachioed cigar chewing rebel babies
in response to male mask phobia public
health officials adapted a more modern
manly form of public health steeped in
discipline patriotism and personal
responsibility
we see this ethos in a 1919 ad which
features a masked guy urging the public
to stamp out the spanish influenza
you know the way manly men do these
patriotic efforts piggybacked off a
massively successful world war 1 ad
campaign which invoked the civic duty
required of every american
an ad from the red cross even warned
that the man woman or child that will
not wear a mask now is a
dangerous slacker similarly american
vaccine campaigns over the years have
also framed getting vaccinations as a
patriotic duty
quite successfully particularly when it
came to eradicating polio
and make no mistake efforts to convince
americans to don masks
were largely effective as historian john
m barry writes in his book the great
influenza
masks were seen everywhere and would
become a symbol of the epidemic
a wide network of churches and charities
developed to produce masks
and millions of americans made their own
at home a gauze-covered face became a
not particularly sexy symbol of your
patriotism
and i know i know getting someone to
help other people so that they feel like
a man is a
very weird ask but hey if it works
can we get the old spice guy in on this
anything is possible when your man
smells like old spice and not a lady i'm
on a horse
now it's important to note that mask
wearing in 1919 wasn't a magic bullet
experts have advanced different theories
as to why masks didn't effectively stop
the spread of influenza
like people made a mask and then wore
them incorrectly or
they didn't wash them enough or they'd
remove them while socializing
shoot email and address donate use shoes
in store what else
roger it's your birthday well it is not
my birthday because that makes sense
also influenza travels in much smaller
airborne droplets than cobin 19.
making it harder to block with a mask
but i digress because
we're talking about how to get people to
wear masks to protect against something
they can actually stop the spread of
the novel coronavirus despite successful
appeals to patriotism and manliness
during the influenza pandemic there was
still plenty of griping and complaining
particularly in places where masks
became legally mandated
most infamously there were the two
thousand or so detractors who formed the
san francisco anti-mass
league but even those who obeyed were
thoroughly annoyed when the mask order
was lifted in san fran after mere weeks
everyone collectively cheered and tore
their masks off leaving the sidewalks
and runnels strewn with the relics of a
tortuous month
clearly americans have a lot of feelings
about the combined indignities of
wearing a mask
and being told what to do this led
scholar laura spenny to suggest in her
book about the 1918 pandemic
that people have a low tolerance for
mandatory health measures
and what's more that such measures are
most effective when they are voluntary
when they respect and depend on
individual choice and when they avoid
the use of police powers
in other words it's sometimes better to
inform citizens with the facts about
masks vaccines seatbelts etc
so as to arm them with information so
that they do the right thing
there's probably a lot of you watching
this who don't drink and drive because
it's a dick move that could kill
somebody
rather than out of a specific fear of
getting arrested
recent evidence suggests that mandates
can increase compliance for mass wearing
seat belts and vaccinations
even if public health experts typically
prefer education over enforcement
indeed spinney notes that a 2007 cdc
pandemic policy
suggested relying on voluntary
compliance with public health measures
unless mortality rates exceed one
percent
the point is there's a limit to how far
playing nice will go for the cdc when
confronting mass death
it's also important to note that even if
we can successfully get most people to
wear masks
it's useless if they do so incorrectly
this was a huge problem during the
spanish flu
tons of people wear crappy masks and
they wore them wrong besides the
aforementioned cigarette holes the very
idea of which makes my head explode
people used inadequate materials like
cheesecloth or they expose their noses
or they recycle dirty masks
we're obviously seeing a similar problem
today with mask fails plaguing everyone
from
nose breathers to people wearing valve
masks that filter air coming
in while expelling diseased air out for
everyone else to enjoy
arguably this could be combated with
more robust messaging about the correct
kinds of masks to wear
and exactly how to wear them
particularly given that americans are
accessible by more methods of
communication than ever before
like why wasn't this youtube video
annoyingly prefaced with a federally
sponsored public health commercial
telling you to cover your mouth and nose
so we're also protected from the coveted
molecules camping out in your boogers
and why isn't the government making fun
twitter videos about hand washing
all in all the 1918 pandemic
demonstrates that education should be
our first line of defense against
pandemics
the influenza pandemic offers a really
simple one-to-one comparison for
examining america's mask phobia
however it's also worth examining
another more recent public health
education effort the
hiv aids epidemic and resulting campaign
to increase condom use
look at the early years of this crisis
and you'll see parallels to our current
predicament
first and foremost there was an entirely
new virus to educate people about
in a healthy individual there are twice
as many t helper cells as t
suppressor cells in people with age this
ratio is reversed
secondly the federal government
basically ignored it and hoped it would
go away
worsening the spread thirdly people who
took it seriously were often mocked
even by president reagan's own press
secretary who responded to one
reporter's questions about aids by
intimating that the reporter was himself
infected with the virus
while the american government was deadly
silent about the virus for years there
were worldwide public health efforts
attempting to promote
awareness in the early 80s mostly by
seriously freaking people out
some ads went so far as to use imagery
of tombstones and grim reapers
as researchers from population action
international found
such campaigns hadn't provided
information about hiv aids
nor suggested new behaviors effective in
preventing hiv acquisition or
transmission
and essentially only increased fear this
approach would be echoed later in the
decade by some american
government-sponsored ads and it was
probably
really not smart that's not because fear
categorically doesn't work one michigan
state meta-analysis of fear-based public
health messaging shows that ads that
aggressively appeal to fear
actually can be highly successful so
long as they are accompanied by the
message that people
can take effective steps to protect
themselves however
fear-based ads like our grim reaper that
don't empower people to protect
themselves are counterproductive
resulting in defensiveness or denial
similar studies have come to the same
conclusions about anti-drug ads like the
infamous
this is your brain on drugs which offers
the viewer no suggestions on how to take
personal action
rather than spurring people to change
their behavior relying purely on fear
seems to make people shut down and
maybe even giggle don't have sex because
you will get pregnant
and die but aids education wasn't all
death incarnate
early on in the epidemic queer activists
stepped up to fill the void created by
u.s governmental inaction and widespread
homophobia
these activists took public health
education into their own hands
for example one 1983 pamphlet made by
activists pioneered the concept of safer
sex
teaching specific behaviors that could
drastically reduce people's risk of
contracting aids without stamping out
their sex lives entirely
such messaging according to public
health scholar taslin j pedomsi
was oriented towards changing individual
behavior by transforming community norms
most specifically by turning condom use
into a common practice for gay men
such community-based educational efforts
were according to podomsi
remarkably effective at stemming the
spread of the disease
accordingly these independent efforts
establish some best
practices in public health that continue
today specifically by encouraging simple
clear directives targeted towards those
who most need to receive the message
in contrast america's government
sponsored aids campaigns in the mid to
late 80s focused on the message that
anyone can get aids without specifying
the critical fact that certain groups
faced a disproportionate risk
here we see the way public health
messaging made by members of a community
for their community can be remarkably
effective and can even kickstart
wider public health efforts which is
probably partially why you
maybe receive somewhat comprehensive sex
ed in school
in other words teaching people how stuff
works is a really good idea
some might say it's the basic foundation
on which this channel was founded
and of course it's messy and tricky and
tiring there are some people who will
not be convinced by any amount of
evidence that this facebook post is not
scientific fact
and there are times when you have to
take extreme action like barring someone
the joy of picking up kung pao
cauliflower in order to make them behave
responsibly
at least temporarily but regardless we
should probably at least try to
educate our friends and loved ones to
please for the love of god
cover your disease holes but in a nice
way
but what do you guys think would
nationwide messages about masks that
stress our patriotic and moral duties be
more effective than
all the twitter shaming in the world or
is getting this guy
to wear a mask is simply impossible let
us know what you think in the comments
huge thanks to our dope patrons for
supporting the channel and our podcasts
hit that subscribe button as always
thanks for watching later
[Music]
hmm